we're rolling we're on let's say like
I'm with Gary Vee thank you this is
incredible this is really awesome for me
to be here today I got my man Jim McGee
who's been with me from the very
beginning it's kind of seen all the
stuff I've had grow over the years he
was a bouncer driving a beat-up Chrysler
300 when I met him I'm on that pretty
much well there was that I was well you
guys weren't in Davis at the time yeah
that was a miss Kelly back in 2005 5m6
somewhere on there you read crush' read
a book called crush it how'd you get a
in for a bit my dad was into it my dad
is the one my dad's a huge mentor to me
much like your dad to you and he's
wanted to kind of told me about it like
that I'm madly into reading that oh no I
hate to read give me tip that you
challenge for me so I get the audio book
and it's you've been better you narrate
and I go oh my god this guy's annoying
as hell that that's right this guy's got
a lot of fight but once I started
listening to it more I was like you were
able to get through that right I was
able to get through that just fine a lot
of these some people know well the
reason I'm able to get through it is
because I realized very quickly into the
book that that's who you are
yeah so when somebody's trying to be
amplified or over-the-top shorts or for
[ __ ] reasons then I'm like [ __ ] - I'll
take anybody in their pure form right I
know honey yeah I enjoy it a lot on some
of the general principles you shared in
that book helped me and my wife
tremendously experience on my best
friend passed away he was a colonel at
Pentagon and ton of people at his
funeral and everybody was saying
fantastic things about it at I knew was
a great guy
but there are people saying that he
changed their the course of their lives
and like I've done that for anything
yeah like how many pallbearers can I
pull the dishes yeah no I get it
Jordan here told me that Fitness has
changed your life and it's been a lot of
money in your bank account is that true
nobody actually said the kind of almost
exact opposite you know it's really
interesting a lot of people ask me about
getting into better shape or less
Kabir's you know it's so funny it's the
same way I think about business in life
do I it's unbelievable to me that I
don't necessarily feel so much better
like we keep you know and you guys
probably are more grounded in this it's
been fun to like realize you keep
finding new spots like oh sure now I've
realized my show that we even look like
those Ben is literally last week you
don't know it I didn't know it three you
know I knew that I was not doing
anything that was smart
with my eating or physical fitness three
years ago which is why I started doing
it you kind of stuff it under the table
yeah I you know I did it because I knew
I wasn't doing the right behavior right
but to say I feel so different there's
little there's a couple little things
like I know when I cut Kerry Zander down
the street weren't one-armed it for four
blocks and they don't get tired after
three steps that makes sense grabbing my
luggage but energy wise I don't feel any
difference because I have so much
natural energy a lot energy anyway but
even though I don't feel these
remarkable short-term results I know
what how this plays out I know what my
life looks like at 74 I know you gotta
understand supply and demand applause go
figure what we've seen in our community
is is people's lifts getting a lot
better
so I'm watching him and watching this
guy watching that guy and because the
lifts have gotten so much bigger now
it's what a 700 pound deadlift used to
be kind of the norm now we're a new one
weren't exceptional well now now we're
seeing yet in the mountain now we're
seeing eight hundred nine hundred
thousand pound deadlifts what do you
think it instagram has done for business
that have done something similar where
they're seeing somebody like you and
it's driving them to that's a really
that's a really good observation so I
think what what that does when you when
you have more awareness of everything
what it does is exposes people so I
don't think there's a general answer of
that right winners say [ __ ] 750 I'm
going 760 a lot of people go the other
way and get
Sturridge and bought bow out it's the
way I think about rich kids
I've now I'd succumb there's something I
try how I thought I was going to fix
this but like I'm aware that my children
will grow up extremely well up and
they're going to do one of two things
once they realize when I'm up to I'm
going to look at that and they are
saying what I did with my dad which for
where we were seemed like a big
accomplishment I'm going to climb that
mountain and I'm gonna I mean I used to
tell my dad like I'm gonna I'm gonna do
so much more than you that you're not
you're going to feel that it's
disrespectful to even put up our names
and I mean I was so competitive of my
own dad like you're not even to say my
name because it can be disrespectful to
compare the two of us I need to get mad
too we were competitive but a lot you
know I've been watch I now I have fancy
friends while our friends third
generation wealth friends and a lot of
kids go completely the other way right
going to be like well I'm not going to
climb that well and actually I kind of
feel guilty that I fly on private jets
and have a Hamptons home so what I'm
actually going to do is I'm going to
take mommy and daddy's money and give it
away I'm gonna be a non-profit or I'm
going to go build homes or and by the
way I'm comfortable with whatever Misha
and Xander decide to do I I genuinely am
but that's what happens when you get
exposed to big things you either decide
to go and the reason you see 800 and
more now is a small percentage of the
great winners put in the triple work
because they're aware and push it
forward one of the biggest reasons
athletes are better in today's world is
Magic Johnson didn't know that Larry
Bird was taking 5,000 free throws yeah
they just found that each other in
college or like damn
yeah now everybody's you know when
you're 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 years old you
real kind of grainy kid that's such a
young you know where you sit and it's
pushing you harder if you're really that
star and so maybe Larry Bird would have
taken 3,000 shot if he knew magic was
taking 1200 alright how old are your
kids 7 and 4 what do you think is most
important thing to do with them in terms
of you know a parent is going to be the
one that has to guide their kids you're
going to have to make your kid do things
that they don't want to do such as like
eat vegetables finish their dinner just
not eat too many too much sugar and so
on right when it comes for 9 1
I think one of the great debates that I
play with now is what is established
cliche eat your vegetables and what is
actually the value of that in reality
right
truth is the far majority of people I
know probably didn't eat their
vegetables for definitely anybody who's
41 ate way too much sugar and just like
soda 24 I mean Frank Soto every day of
my life to me the things I think most
about are number one two three and four
is to build self-esteem so my belief is
that self-esteem is the only drug that
combats the world yeah I genuinely
believe powerful in parallel it's
imperative that you don't build fake
self-esteem self-esteem can't be
manufactured through rewarding non
rewarding events the paper says
participation trophies correct you can't
come in eighth place in the race in
school and then get prized for that
because that's just not realized me
however Xander for example this weekend
when Max got hurt his nephew stopped
what he was doing and came over and
showed amazing empathy for a
four-year-old that has become now the
thing I've talked to him about for two
days yeah he's incredible that you have
such a great heart like to mean triple
damages by the way this is me being a
byproduct of being what I think
perfectly parented this is what my mom
did yeah my mom over-exaggerated my
natural goodness as a person to make me
believe it was like the most important
thing and she never gave me third place
trophies and when I lost I lost and she
made me realize her repercussions in
life so when I got bad grades even
though she knew I was going to be very
special
I was literally punished like it was
like clockwork you know like the Sun and
the moon do their thing from fifth grade
to senior of high school to senior of
high school I was punished every single
mid-october at the first report card is
late December her early March and the
end of the year age from literally from
fifth grade for seven to eight years
consistent
I was grounded yeah I mean I you know I
think it's interesting I think that I
think that subconsciously I knew that it
wasn't the most important thing in the
world but I do like that she punished me
and didn't let me completely disrespect
the system but she never let it hurt my
confidence right she played it very fun
and there is something interesting my
parents did at 14 and they said look
tough guy you're not going to be a
student things are going to work and so
that means you can start working now
yeah and so I do think one of the great
things my parents did I think a lot of
parents to think about this is if you
don't have a student even if they're an
artist and want to sing and paint you
need to figure out how to establish
massive work ethic because the only
thing that's controllable for somebody
who's going to bet on themselves in life
is their work ethic their talent you can
get it better right you can lift more
you can get better at things but
something like my calves and ass aren't
naturally that's the same as everybody
else owners people are naturally like I
don't like my chest is never going to be
as big as I necessarily want it if
there's certain things that are right
but meanwhile like mouths sell you back
the Hat you're wearing right now right
I will and so I think that I think it's
important to teach work ethic because
worth that work ethic is the only thing
that maximizes what you naturally have
and that's really the best you can ask
for what about sports is that sports for
your children I'm very into it I'm a
little worried about what the New York
City dynamic of sports is I didn't grow
up life's are confusing that it seems
like to me like they're yet to be a part
of something for so long and it seems
like it's your fortune kwikki different
here's what here's what I would say I'm
going to use sports a little bit
differently I'm obsessed with
competition and I think and I really
hope my kids are competitive one I'll
say again I'm not interested in posing
any of my will on them if they if
they're not competitive
they'll be disappointing because I love
it for about 4 seconds and then I'll
trick myself at the fitting it's great
like I'm just going to go optimistic on
it but sports at school team team sports
are cool think it teaches people a lot
of things i seduce
it might learn yeah here's what I know
that I love sports I love sports I love
sports
my kids have shown interest in sports
this year for the first time in a
meaningful way my daughter especially
which is a lot of fun for me
yeah again I'm very weird like like I I
really want to reverse engineer my kids
right I want to pay attention to their
actions figure out what's driving them
and then quadruple down on it and then
instill the spirit of reality into it
how do you pay attention to them with so
many different things going on that's
hard it's hard and I would tell you that
that's probably time zero sorry I don't
I just read out of your shoulder no I
think my answer is I try yeah
personally I work too much so the
limited time I have with them I try to
stay focused but like I'm selfish in my
own stuff too I think it's important to
be you know I think one of the things I
worry about with a lot of stay-at-home
parents and obviously I don't know what
the percentage ours but you know I think
we still live in a world where it's
gotta be in the 80s maybe in the 90s
that the woman's staying at home I watch
all the cleaners incredible women that
work for me women entrepreneurs when
they you know it's been interesting for
me it feels like such a difficult game
you know guys have it so easy when
children come to the equation I feel
like there's an enormous amount of I you
know it's the balance of guilt of
keeping your own identity of you know so
many of these women you know women are
we're not living in a great age where
it's not the archaic ages anymore
there's a lot of women that have
unbelievable ambitions the greatest
ambitions equal to the ambitions of men
which they didn't have 50 60 30 90 years
ago and so like that transition seems
very difficult and I think when you use
yourself in your children you lose yeah
you lose which that means your children
lose one of the things that one of the
things that I'm very very obsessed with
is I can't believe how many parents wrap
their own self-esteem and to their
children's accomplishments as well so
this has been this has been the big
eye-opener for me
this was probably the one thing I didn't
I anticipated quite a bit about
parenting I think I nailed it I'm good
at predicting [ __ ]
here's where I missed by a mile like
literally it struck me at a at a parent
event I was like wait a minute wait a
minute
you actually feel better about yourself
because your kid can play chess
I don't you not you love your kid and
you're happy for your kids no you ya
think you're better cuz you're the
parent of the check later I it blew me
away my parents never wrapped their
self-esteem in me I wrap my self-esteem
and only myself not even my parents like
up
I couldn't even under I am very
empathetic which is one good salesmen
who I'm successful a lot of that's my
gift gratitude and empathy I was an
empathy empathetic to that excitement
lived it I've never tasted it I'd never
understood it and then it opened up
everything like that why people put
bumper stickers of like Harvard you know
I'm like oh [ __ ] that's why parents
force their kids into collecting debt to
go to a university that makes the parent
feel good versus the kid going to a
secondary school or Community College
where they don't like it's quick it
unlocked the whole world of like [ __ ]
you parents that's what I thought in
Little League with my older son there
were two of the assistant coaches for
his team would they have to call the
sheriff to calm him down because if
there was a call at home place that they
didn't like or a striker one that I
actually agree with I want to fight I
guess sports muscle that to me is a
little that that to me is a could be a
nuanced event that could be true if Rick
wants to fight because he thinks he's
little Timmy and he's a great baseball
player I can just fight because I just
want my kids team to win the game yeah I
just want to win the game but like but
like it pretty easy for me to mean those
kind of things actually don't really
freak me out as much as the politically
correct world gets freaked out I just
don't think it makes any sense and
you're a parent you're number one thing
in the world is to do everything right
by that
child-like threat your mercy they like
your kid and and parents are are
misfiring their their cell that's a
quote before the best way to have an
impact on the world is to go home and
love your family river that form mm-hmm
my mother Teresa it's alright I think
it's great it makes a lot of sense to me
because I'm trying to impact you know
lifters like yes trying to impact
trainers yes and people to fitness
industry I'm super excited about it then
I'm at home and I'm in my phone I get it
man and my little girl get it daddy
daddy daddy and I'm like what am i why
am i doing I get it and I can I and I
think that's right and I also think you
know I think it comes down to your
circumstance - all right so on the son
of the first-generation immigrant who
worked every minute left before I woke
up came home after I slept slept in the
home that I slept in every single night
took zero travel days so was in the same
home my dad slept and it's not a divorce
this is not a traveling father like I am
this is my father slept in the same home
that I slept in my entire life
um I just want everybody to hear this
because is insane actually in hindsight
from the day was born to the day I left
like all of them like like old school
like like just came home every night I
don't know what have to tell you and I
never saw him once and when I tell you I
never saw him once I spent more time
with my kids
this Presidents Day weekend and my dad
did with me my entire childhood combined
like I just want Pete like I don't think
people really like you know even look
like in resentful or was it didn't even
cross my mind of it thanks thank god dad
works so hard we came from nothing now
we have a town house that's what it was
it was gratitude it was optimism and
there wasn't a need my mom was so
incredible and again every kid's
different I didn't need my debt did I
notice that a lot of people dads were at
the Little League games absolutely did
my dad went to one little league game my
entire career I was pumped and I'd be
good it was an all-star game I played
well like but again I was a kid that
didn't need it I didn't mean my dad I
definitely needed my mom you need
but like I didn't need anything I didn't
I've never been somebody who validates
himself on anything on the outside and
that is a gift and I think that goes
back to have one can yeah look they're
gonna be different right they're good
honey they're different and so like you
got to look like like Misha my daughter
reminds me of me she never gave a [ __ ]
that I would leave the house by that you
shall be gone for four days I'll be back
by that my little guys like that like
not and he's and I'm like oh [ __ ] this
look I didn't realize how good I had it
with Misha like this actually hurts my
feelings I'm emotional this is sad like
and you'll adjust the other thing is I
just said Tyler my admin like hey this
is and this is where I was going with
this is very long-winded to thing that I
how old are you kids right so you guys
are really in this zone you know how for
the vegetables thing right I'm very
against that let me explain how what I
mean is vegetable soup I like I'm in a
[ __ ] state well actually there's a
huge ironing you know this I love that
today I'm against the cliche thing so
one of the biggest conversation I'm
having with my wife right now is like
look Lizzie I go to Oslo Hong Kong
Melbourne I'm going on all these amazing
trips I'm like you need to start I know
that you're a little bit more by the
book it's my wife like I need you to be
open to what I want to do which is me
she was going to miss 13 days of school
a year that makes no sense and they're
going to and that's because I'm going to
take her to Oslo and she's going to see
what daddy does and we're going to spend
six hours on the eight hours on the
plane together and then I'm gonna take
an action what will change and you
change right now I'm in every play I
don't know when I sleep in one place
twice we stopped in Belgium two nights
it's weird I stay nowhere in more than
one night nowhere trips are to Europe
and Asia
these are eight-hour trips 9:00 our
trips 13 our trips they are insane right
we want that right I went to Dublin and
didn't like memory and slept there right
like West one from New York overnight to
Dublin Dublin speech get on a plane go
to Belgium it's why we had two nights in
Belgium so but now I'll just now that
the kids you know you get to adjust you
get to be a parent forever yeah all
these parents want to win in the first
inning
right right there's more to it now I do
think the early years are foundational I
don't disrespect them
I do think feelings get formulated at
six nine twelve fourteen nineteen that
may be harder but let's be honest I need
people to understand I'm going to paint
a picture that everybody knows is true
and should really make all parents feel
better about themselves and not make
them crippled how many times do you need
to see a child reunited with a parent
that did everything wrong walked out on
them didn't give a crap about them
cheated on their spouse stole the money
we're an alcoholic
it takes the kid oh but five minutes cuz
I get one or two things off their chest
and they're back into the need to
rebuild that relationship
these are children like this thought
it's so big in my man and a modern
modern nitpicking and political
correctness is trying to scare us into
thinking we're [ __ ] this up which is
how a helicopter correct and then these
kids are losers like so so look do I
wish I spend more time with my kids
of course do I think the things that I'm
doing will impact my kids in a positive
way absolutely yeah I genuinely do well
supplying the man the scarcity he really
appreciates yeah and I don't want to win
on you right and I don't want to win on
that but you're not wrong and I don't
want them to take the mother for granted
because she deserves the curtain like oh
so much I'm more upset I'd be more
reactionary to that because of that
because I think she deserves I hate when
people get taken for granted I live my
life getting taken for granted because
the way I roll some very anti that so it
won't be a hypocrite and do that to my
wife you know and then and then I'm like
I break every rule because I want to
like it's so amazing it's so hard coming
from nothing I don't want to give them
anything I want to give them everything
you know I think we all go through it
listen there's nothing I've said that
every parent isn't or shaking their head
about because we're all living it here's
the thing I am saying that's different
you're doing way better than you think
I'm just tired of this like first of all
I don't give a [ __ ] about what your
opinion is on how impairing they're my
kids [ __ ] face like like like and more
importantly my mom
was snickered at her whole life because
they never went anywhere there were no
family vacations she parented me and all
the Brooklyn Russian families they go at
second they made a few bucks they went
on every cruise and this and that and
now and every Russian wedding my parents
are put on a throne because of the way
that her three kids ended up right
comparison that's amazing and so to that
point why I told that stories one to
give my parents credit and to this
please out you can have opinions about
how I'm parenting let's see how it plays
out so long yeah
let's see what's better kids see which
kids are winners and happy and winning
is comes in different forms I know
miserable billionaires I know kid when I
grew up with nothing but money
he's success right now and what does he
do every night he does coke every night
that's what he does and you know like
he's gonna lose like right and then I
know kids right but everybody on because
of his Instagram thinks he's winning you
think he's winning he lost meanwhile I
have friends that I grew up with great
parenting still live in hundred-and
County New Jersey like going to the ball
is like the legit thing right and
they've won so it's not just winning a
like who like right like goals like not
right my parents are talented because of
what I've achieved yes because what I've
achieved but who I am I think we said
earlier about being selfish is really
important if some might preach a lot of
times at seminars too is that you have
to go out there and you have to figure
out a way to take care of yourself first
the things that you love the first so if
you love doing this and you love being
here this is crucial and you can't take
care of him you can't take care of him
perfect five hundred other people that
were first still 750 and and first I'm
the engine if I break everybody else is
[ __ ] now for me what really got lucky
was I'm bill like my mom which is my
fuel for that engine is to make other
people happy which makes me popular
which makes me even more popular two
people that know me the best which is
really by the way the way I judge myself
the way I've basically been judging
myself through this really interesting
path I'm living right now is do the
people that know me the best like me the
like see pumped about going to Belgium
but there is he like [ __ ] before
inevitably like when he's getting six or
seven DMS a month of like fish stick
like like back to the first rate like my
stuff comes off with a stick because I'm
an anomaly I am over energized I am
pumped I am more grateful I am louder I
am like more confident I am different I
am I'm different and I like that I like
when I got a legit message you they
asked me you're really just a real
person to get the people like oh that's
a good one
yeah see like to me that like that just
funny yeah like just like ah when I hear
that I would think that if I planted a
human to take a selfie with me to act
cool in a daily being that that single
move would crumble my entire empire
because what then I would have to make
all these people that actually know I
have to keep them on the payroll I want
to find her I want to fire these guys I
mean furious like one of the biggest
reasons like really no interest in being
held hostage the reason you need to live
naked is because you don't want anybody
to have leverage over you I'm not
letting anybody have the upper hand on
me he would have the upper hand if I
needed to make sure that he told them
known enough you know [ __ ] that and you
can't hold those plates eventually one
Falls and then it's over
so one of the reasons I leaved lived
that kind of life as leverage how's your
wife has she been a part of a lot of
success of will you build up she's the
foundation of my success she's the
enabler of my success if my wife if my
wife wasn't so selfless I wouldn't be
what I am today and and you know it as a
young man I didn't understand that you
know like see my gear is so driven that
yeah he would just kind of form that way
yes and that's like 16 like the thought
like that like if I my mom would be a
month as I grew up my mom's teaching me
to be a good man we'd have these
conversations and I'm like
you didn't build the liquor store that
built the liquor stores
how are you taking credit for are you
saying we not yeah and uh and of course
you know what you realize is when you
start tasting life is I can't you know I
spent zero minutes worrying about what
Lizzy's thinking anytime always which
allows me to do 100% my thing right
which is a gift and a curse
one it's such a blessing to have someone
like that be your support system second
it's daunting because I'm just always
petrified to take it for granted and you
she does what I do that's why I think I
think we love each other so much because
we're similar our real Korres and we
love ourselves so much that I think it
makes us appreciate the other one um
yeah she's a big deal can you talk about
is this to her no no no and by the way I
could and she's more than capable she's
got it like that
I don't want to I actually don't talk
about the business at all like I keep it
very like even like letting you know
it's funny I've drawn here like - I
spend more time I spend as much time
with Jordans I do with my wife like see
them every day for an hour us like you
know I don't complain I don't talk about
stuff once in a blue moon it's like I'm
probably the things I've told him have
been more predicated on trying to teach
him how to be a businessman than the
need to get it out so you trying to
trying to cheat you trying to I like she
should yeah yeah I like men I like it I
like it I I'm a great like teammate
coach Lee I'm a great leader I just know
it I'm a great leader because I care
about them more than I care about myself
which then makes them care enough about
me that it matters it's fun apologize
Ivy what Tyler literally came here to
work for me for a year learn I guess get
them I mean I'm speaking for you on this
upfront get the brand Association get
the exposure steel from your label
perfect it's not you know I would call
it like get return value because you
know I really I feel like I'm there
want to do that part and by the way the
best part is I'm fine with that too
because I'm on to the next thing the
next day but very quickly and we have
this conversation I'm actually how
quickly do you realize maybe I shouldn't
just say for a year maybe I should play
this out a little bit longer
like how quickly like seriously dumb
[ __ ] that's it
that's great leadership but right young
man comes with a plan for his own and
realized wait a minute there's so much
good here for me maybe what's because it
you're not doing that because he's been
tricked by me he's doing it because he
thinks it's in his best interest to be
part of the hundreds of Mike who was my
last trainer before Jordan like the last
couple months I could tell he was like
theblakes
maybe I shouldn't leave my god right oh
into boxing I heard a kind of I'm
actually going to box on Fridays the
boxer the kid and one of our neighbors
use the box and so I said dude you gotta
shake my hand right now and pick me up
at 6:00 a.m. otherwise I won't [ __ ]
go we'll just talk a little bit I'm
excited about that you know you talk
kind of recently about return on
investment and you talked about how
that's everyone's kind of like first
thought is how do I get my money back
how do I get my money back on this
Facebook post this Instagram post and
tactics tactics over religion yeah I've
heard you talk about that before so my
gym is free and when I made my gym three
years ago somebody said why did you make
the gym free I said to become a
millionaire and my friend it was a
liquor center Wow long story long go
figure
yeah laughter he's the intro voice of
the podcast Billy but anyway he just
kind of tapped me on the shoulder he's
like I believe in what you just said
like I I can see in your eyes I know
what your another cool it's cool so the
whole reason for making the gym free was
a bunch of reason but one number reason
number one was to pay it back to power
think I've gotten so much out of power
of things I've got people helping on
your channel team and haven't ya round
me ten I lift me and push me forward
that I felt amazing about it but in your
situation you know how do you kind of
you get back your return maybe in a
different way it's not money money it's
I mean and I'm making a joke I think
that people are not smart and let me
tell you what I mean by that I am so
confused by people's inability to
understand what's happening everything
is predicated on action like it's just
actions I don't listen to what anybody
says I just pay attention to what they
do so for me you know I have very big
ambitions but one thing that I don't
think I'm blown away by people not
remembering that for 13 years of my life
out of school I didn't build a brand I
wasn't speaking I wasn't Gary B my name
was Gary Vaynerchuk and I worked in a
liquor store every single day and I
built an e-commerce business and built
fulfillment these are things I don't
talk about I invented fulfillment I
didn't know I didn't go to school for
fulfillment and that the fulfillment for
myself you know I didn't know Sharon or
cool what's before just many didn't have
it and I don't think I did it I honestly
I actually think I actually I think I've
been a small piece of it but a very
small bit I will tell you I think that
it was the Facebook movie that made it
cool I think it's I think it's the
extreme wealth at such a young age
billionaires were 60 and old and no
eighteen year old could associate with
that when they were like wait a minute
that dudes a billionaire and he's
wearing a hoodie and sneakers and he's
27 that changed everything right I think
I rode the wave that was created more so
than health you know like now the good
thing is it was my truth unlike
everybody else who was like meant to be
a trainer but now says they're an
entrepreneur and a trainer because it's
cool or they want to sell schlagg on
Instagram or easier I'm going what's
been fun for me is it's my
truth like like that's fun right this
isn't a fly-by-night thing this was my
truth and so yeah I mean I think that I
did so I think to answer your question
it's not the money
anybody that's really smart would know I
knew how to make money before I became
me I made money before I became me when
I invested in Twitter and Tumblr and
uber that was before I became who
everybody knows me as I don't need to
monetize my audience I don't want you
know I'll take this opportunity make
sure you use it I don't think people
that monetize their audience I'm just
reminding them that I don't I'm just
it's just a cut it's an important
conversation and somebody will jump in
and say will ya Gary what about your
books and your your t-shirts and then I
would say again you are not smart
because if you understood the economics
behind that in comparison to what I do I
will make more money giving one speech
then I will in everything I do in
t-shirts this entire year don't you
think it'd be smarter for me to do that
I do it because it's fun I like somebody
wearing a t-shirt with my coat on it
because I am vain and I like it
right I like I like giving them out
because everybody I noticed like again
people are not smart when I started this
60-second Club and it's working for me
on Instagram I'm giving away my books a
lot of people have the books so if I
create t-shirts it's something for me to
give back which creates even more of a
relationship and by the way I want to
remind everybody I am by hand not
somebody here you notice you know this I
need you by hand going into my comments
reading it replying to day one tagging
them screen shooting it drawing and like
you know I'm like I'm doing it and so so
my answer is very simple I want to leave
a legacy I want to be the greatest most
admired Entrepreneur of all time and I
want to do it by not amassing the most
wealth
I want to do it by amassing the most
wealth and give back to the community in
parallel because I am leaving enormous
amounts of money on the table by doing
what I'm doing in content and yeah to
people not remember all these people
cost me money he cost me more money than
all the money I'll make on t-shirts this
year it's not a good trade you don't
charge a lot you know like they don't
get it and by the way I am not mad
because 99% of the people are not good
enough businesspeople to go through the
whole process of their brain something
mad I just disagree with people's
opinions when when they you know and I
laugh at what their comments and I
enjoyed the negative comments and social
because it drives me and reminds me that
one I need to respect and be grounded at
all times and to that I'm just
dramatically smarter than a lot of
people so we got you a deadlift thing we
got you into into some fitness yes how
do we get you on a cycle of steroids
this is the funny this is a funny
conversation this is vegetables to me
and I brought this up to you I don't
think I'm going to do it because I think
I'm too grounded in its vegetables but I
and I'm not educated but I can tell you
right now I'm very fascinated from the
couple of heads so the reason I don't
want to speak about this is less about
me not wanting to do steroids is I don't
want to be a hypocrite I make fun of an
you know this headline readers I know
what's going on in Facebook and snapchat
and Instagram and I don't I know the
headlines are many steroids isn't as bad
as you necessarily think please maybe
after a certain age it's maybe not at 16
it's scarier than maybe if you're 45
like I'm actually weirdly fascinated by
it but I also know my headline reader
it's a couple conversations with Mike
it's Aqaba conversations him it's a
couple tweets I've seen it's a couple of
things I've heard yeah but you know like
to me smoking was fine for you in 1947
I'll tell you right now I'm Way more
scared about putting a cell phone to my
head and getting brain cancer than
steroids so like I think people are not
smart and so I would tell you that if I
had to make prediction I would tell you
it's not out of the question for me to
do a cycle I'm being serious I'm back
you'll be just jack it's not it's not
it's not out of the question now I mean
I am a little bit of a purist aka
I love I'm still enjoying because you
know how long have you been working out
those 12 good words good so you've seen
it like this is the first time in my
life that I'm actually seeing something
happen out of the work you put in some
enjoy right so I mean I'm actually a
pure like it's the reason I'm do it the
same reason I'm doing all my own social
media is the same reason I would
probably not be steroids because of that
because I like doing it right more so
than me thinking it's bad or what got it
yeah sounds like yeah so there were
steroids that helped people in business
what things with it what do you improve
about emotional intelligence empathy
gratitude self-awareness the businesses
break because human brains break them
companies don't get bigger because all
these [ __ ] want to micromanage
everything because it makes them feel
better if you spread all the world's
wealth they've said before you spread
all the world's wealth around everybody
equally it would end up in the pockets
of the rich in a very short period of
time of course talent is the first item
it's not colleges talent right winners
win like that's just a game and so the
people that are not in a path of winning
need to do something drastically to
break their behavior because that's why
they're not winning normally it's
Association of something in someone else
one of the things that is driving me
more than ever is for some reason my
communication style penetrates people
that are not normally penetrated by
communication styles and to be very
frank with you I feel guilty if I didn't
continue down that path because
it's helping people I mean yeah I don't
know what else to say it's [ __ ]
awesome
when I listen to you with what resonates
with me is it almost feels like I'm
listening to a podcast or listening to a
conversation as if I'm in AI feel like
I'm part of it it's like I'm in the room
as well and we know from doing this part
of us that we've had a similar impact on
people where there's been people that
are listening to in their cars well I'll
tell you shouting well well I'll tell
you and I'll give you a nice compliment
I even feel it while you're doing this
this feels much more like we're actually
hanging out then I'm doing a podcast
genuine now and I do a lot of them and
some people good at it but maybe even
the dynamic of two of you like and maybe
no question cuz I know myself having
them three here but like I feel it make
sense I think part of it too the people
Elizabeth attached with your buzz and I
learn I'm obsessed with audio like and
again watch me don't listen to what I
said I even talked a lot about
podcasting but if you guys are consuming
me I rebranded it from the askgaryvee
show to the Gary B audio experience
right I I started pushing it very
aggressively in my social channels
I created a podcast tab in on my website
I took it to all platforms SoundCloud
and Spotify I if you really watch every
single piece of my content hired an
audio guy because you've seen them in a
couple of shots like like don't like I
haven't gotten to tell you about
podcasting or anybody about podcasting
one it's been covered very well I'm not
a podcasting pioneer this has been
around Ferris and Rogan and Louis Howell
I'm gonna split the pass when there's
plenty people that people done it people
talked about it people understand it
it's just that I'm like so that's why I
keep saying watch me don't listen to me
make sense yeah I think so
back that I brought up earlier right
yeah I don't I don't listen to what
you're saying I want to see your ad you
I love them people like I'm like
everybody's I'm a good person
I have never tweeted a single donation
I've ever given I'm more than willing to
bring out my tax form right now
instantly
I always think that's we have you know I
always think that's weird it's you think
it's weird because of how you're
grounded yeah you think it's weird for
some reason I think it's weird because
you can taste the [ __ ] behind it
doesn't face very there's only one
reason you like me is because I'm the
pure version of it that's right I know
and so the reason I don't do that is I'm
not tricked by somebody saying just
donate it to Haiti after the but they're
doing it for their own selves
one of my favorite things that you talk
about is uh not being fancy yes so if we
could just end on a fancy break let's do
it do it then I would be more than
satisfied okay good you want to expand
on it yeah absolutely I don't think when
you make your first [ __ ] dollars you
need a [ __ ] Lambo i I don't
understand that people don't understand
that like I love it I mean I you know I
listen again empathy you never had
anything you just were broke I mean you
like it sounds like yeah I'd love to
hear a little more details like I'm not
mad if you want to go buy a nice purse
or nice watch I'm not mad I just I think
it's important by the way let me talk
about a flaw I actually think I'm very
bad at that
I don't celebrate [ __ ] well you know
like [ __ ] I'm like this is actual
conversation between me and my brother
my brother excellent in the sense that
it will prevent you from potentially
being an addict yeah yeah I know because
you would want to celebrate thanks all
right maybe maybe but like no it's
actually way worse than that much it's
like actually like not even
acknowledging it like it's actually
quite selfish and respond a touchdown
flipping the ball over there you know
it's so funny I'm such a polar opposite
like it's so weird that's exactly what
it is yet
until you just said that I would have
thought that I would have been tio if I
was in football and what it likes like I
would think that you know and I do think
and I do think my strength comes in you
know I often think that I'll call my
autobiography you know obviously I have
the honey Empire thing now there's a big
part of me two things to be really funny
that I just called it he did it because
when I buy the Jets you know but I do
think the purest form of my auto black
like the purest title of my life is
going to be the bridge I think I pull so
hard
from opposite directions and a lot of my
clique you know like yeah I mean you
know what it is very strong okay no yeah
actually actually I mean articulate is
more for you than anything else
at a macro on the least fancy in a micro
I can be dancing right right like like
yeah like in my micro onstage but in my
it's almost like in my it's a fake in
the sizzle I got lots of sizzle but my
[ __ ] steak is you know like that's it
right so fancy I you know generally for
your audience I think that to many of
you want stuff and it's the quickest way
to not have stuff I make product and any
time I've gotten a fancy when it hits me
right back in the face that doesn't
[ __ ] work now my I thought this was
such a good idea I had all these
intentions I had all the best intentions
and I tried to fancy it up and it's
[ __ ] up and I think and I think one of
the biggest reasons I'm upset with
entrepreneurship through Instagram
Instagram entrepreneurs access to the
new term Instagram entrepreneurs have
set me because they only push watches
and hot chicks and private planes and
and it out to me it's the process to me
you know you know when Jordan I talk
about working out and when he's
impressed with me you're happy with me
just makes so much sense to me because I
am happy I don't need to like dress up
and go to Equinox you know I need to
just you guys all like that huh those
good luck all right now
ah I need to just put in the work like I
like the grind I like the process and I
even like this I even let you know
what's funny no probably tell you this
I like the steps back I kind of weirdly
enjoy I get mad when I know I have bad
session and I work out seven days a week
now we also like one day could be like
just it's like we're just rolling out as
yeah yeah yeah but I'm there seven days
a week and some days and some things
don't make sense like some days was like
the day before was a soft tissue day and
such the super estimate solid day asleep
and somehow just can click in other days
like he'll go back and actually answer
that person he's not human because I
just watched him sleep three four and
five hours and have the three best
workout I don't even understand it and
he's 41 you feel like you know anyways
I've been doing like so I like I like
the ups and downs
I love the journey my man I love the
journey of life I love the journey of
business I love the journey I'm going
through with fitness I love the process
you have to love the process if you love
the process you've already won it's how
you fix it
the way you fix the game like the way
you hedge it the way it's like you fix
it like fixing it like I fixed my
outcome I don't give a [ __ ] if I buy the
Jets the ambition to and the journey to
try to achieve it right is the game the
Jets are so [ __ ] I thought a fix in
New York I've been a fan forever and
they've been the bad bruh we have been
so fun listen the long we got ringback
[ __ ] ken O'Brien or Richard Todd you
know I think the I think the I think the
truth is like that only fits my
narrative more because when the prodigal
son comes home and dies them and bring
the championship I'll get to be the
LeBron of the job is oh my god thank you
so much for making I appreciate it thank
you so much
you